Pergunta interessante: ácido alfalipoico
ou NAC? Qual é o melhor pro fígado
sobrecarregado? Tudo bem com vocês?
Pessoal, hoje eu vou bater um papo super
importante sobre um dilema que eu recebo
direto no consultório. Sabe quando você
sente que exagerou um pouquinho nas
festas de final de ano ou tá tomando
vários remédios e fica preocupado com o
fígado? Pois é. Muita gente me pergunta:
"Doutor, é melhor tomar o álfalipoico ou
nacestisteína
para dar uma força pro meu fígado?" Eu
não diria que é um é tão melhor do que o
outro. Eles são mais complementares, mas
vamos tentar responder isso da melhor
forma possível. Prometo que vai ser tipo
uma conversa de boteco, só que sobre
bioquímica mais calma, sem neura.
Imagina que o seu fígado é tipo aquele
amigo orcaholic da turma. Ele trabalha
24 horas por dia, 7 dias por semana,
processando tudo que você come, bebe,
respira. até aquele remedinho para dor
de cabeça. E quando a gente exagera,
coitado, ele fica sobrecarregado mesmo.
E aí que entram nossos dois heróis de
hoje, o Nak, que é a inestiteína para
quem gosta de nome complicado, e o astro
alfalipoico ou ala pros íntimos. Os dois
são tipo superheróis do fígado, mas cada
um tem o seu super poder especial. Eu
vou começar pelo NAC, porque ele é o
queridinho dos prontos socorros. Sabe
quando alguém toma paracetamol ou
tilenol demais? O NAC é literalmente o
antídoto oficial, mas não é só isso não.
O NAC funciona como se fosse um personal
trainer da gluta?
Mas o que que é gluta? Você deve estar
se perguntando bem, pensa assim, a gluta
é tipo detergente mais potente que o seu
corpo produz naturalmente. É ela que
limpa as toxinas, neutraliza os radicais
livres, é a faxineira chefe do seu
organismo. E o NAC, ele é o precursor
direto dela. É como se ele entregasse os
ingredientes prontos pro seu corpo
fabricar mais lutatona rapidinho. Por
isso que quando o fígado tá pedindo
socorro, tipo numa intoxicação aguda ou
quando você exagerou no happy hour, o
NAC entra em ação na velocidade da luz.
Estudos recentes 2024 e 2025 mostram que
o NAC continua sendo campeão quando o
assunto é proteção hepática aguda. Ele
reduz as enzimas hepáticas aumentadas,
protege as células do fígado,
hepatócitos. Ainda tem um histórico de
segurança invejável. É tipo aquele
remédio que a sua avó já conhecia e que
continua funcionando maravilhosamente
bem. E não é só pro fígado não, viu? Oc
também ajuda na saúde respiratória, na
recuperação muscular, mas hoje o nosso
foco é o fígado. Então vamos continuar.
Agora vamos falar do ácido alfalipôico,
que é um pouquinho diferente. Se o NAC é
o bombeiro que apaga o incêndio. O ala
alfalipôico é mais como um arquiteto que
reforma a casa toda. O ala é um
antioxidante universal. Esse nome
pomposo significa que ele funciona tanto
em ambientes acuosos quanto gordurosos
do corpo. É tipo um faz tudo. Ele não só
combate os radicais livres diretamente,
mas também regenera outros
antioxidantes. É como se ele
recarregasse as baterias da vitamina C,
da vitamina E, olha só, até da própria
glota. O que mais me impressiona no ala
é que a sua ação nas mitocôndrias é
fantástica. Para quem não lembra das
aulas de biologia, as mitocôndrias são
as usinas de energia das células e o
fígado tem milhares delas. O ala entra
lá dentro e ajuda a otimizar a produção
de energia, melhorando todo o
metabolismo hepático. Isso é
especialmente importante quando falamos
de fígado gorduroso, aquela famosa
esteatose hepática. O ala ele ajuda a
regular o metabolismo dos lipídios, das
gorduras, reduzindo o acúmulo de gordura
do fígado. É como se ele fosse um
personal trainer mais das células
hepáticas. Agora vem a pergunta de R$ 1
milhão deais. Qual dos dois escolher?
Olha, depois de analisar os estudos mais
recentes e minha experiência clínica, eu
posso dizer que depende muito da
situação. É tipo perguntar se é melhor
ter um extintor de incêndio ou um
sistema de prevenção contra incêndios em
casa. Os dois são importantes e se você
fosse perguntar isso para mim, eu
preferia ter os dois ao mesmo tempo, se
não houver uma contraindicação clara pro
uso isolado de cada um deles. Porém, se
você teve uma sobrecarga aguda, bebeu
demais no final de semana, tomou muito
remédio, teve uma intoxicação alimentar,
NAC é a sua melhor escolha. Ele age
rápido, é super seguro e tem décadas de
uso comprovado. A dose usual é de 600 a
1200 mg por dia, mas pode ser muito mais
do que isso, mas sempre consulte o seu
médico, ok? Agora, se você tem um
problema crônico, fígado gorduroso,
síndrome metabólica, aquele conjunto de
alterações nos exames de sangue, ou
simplesmente quer uma proteção
antioxidante de longo prazo, o ácido
falipoco pode ser mais interessante. Ele
trabalha de maneira mais ampla,
melhorando não só a função hepática, mas
todo o metabolismo energético. As doses
de ala geralmente variam de 300 a 600 mg
por dia e o legal é que ele também ajuda
no controle do açúcar, no controle
glicêmico. Então, para quem tem
pré-diabetes ou diabetes, é dois coelhos
numa caja dada só. Uma coisa importante
que eu descobri pesquisando os estudos
mais recentes, alguns pesquisadores
sugerem cautela ao combinar os dois. Em
certas situações, em doses mais altas,
eles podem gerar um efeito proxidante
paradoxal. É como misturar dois produtos
de limpeza muito forte, às vezes pode
dar ruim. Por isso, se você quiser usar
os dois juntos, isso principalmente sem
orientação médica direta, o ideal é
alternar. Por exemplo, usa o NAC por
mês, faz uma pausa, depois usa o ala ou
usa um de manhã e outro à noite, sempre
de preferência com acompanhamento
profissional. Deixa contar um caso real
rapidinho. Tinha uma paciente minha
executiva, 45 anos, estressada, comia
mal, bebia socialmente, mas com
frequência, fez exames e as enzimas
hepáticas estavam nas alturas, além de
tristeatose hepática moderada. Começamos
com 600 mg duas vezes ao dia por 30 dias
para dar uma ressetada no fígado e
depois mantivemos com ácido folipôico
300 mg por dia junto com mudança no
estilo de vida. Em se meses, o fígado
dela estava tinindo, as enzimas
normalizaram e a gordura hepática
reduziu de maneira significativa. Mas
olha, não adianta nada tomar suplemento
e continuar maltratando o fígado, não é?
É tipo tomar remédio para dor de cabeça
e continuar batendo a cabeça na parede.
O ideal é combinar a suplementação com
redução de álcool, que para algumas
pessoas pode ser difícil, mas o fígado
agradece. Alimentação mais natural e
menos processada. Exercícios regulares,
nem que seja uma caminhada de 30 minutos
por dia. Controle do stress, meditação,
yoga, mindfulness ou até mesmo contato
com a natureza ou assistir sua série
favorita e sono adequado. O fígado faz
faxina, principalmente madrugada.
Resumindo nossa conversa de hoje, tanto
nacido alfalipoico são excelentes pro
fígado, mas cada um tem o seu momento
ideal. O NAC é o herói das emergências.
agindo rápido na desintoxicação e
proteção aguda. Já o alfa lipoico é o
estrategista de longo prazo, melhorando
o metabolismo e oferecendo proteção
antioxidante ampla. Na dúvida, converse
com o seu médico ou nutricionista. Cada
caso é único e o que funciona pro seu
vizinho pode não ser ideal para você. O
importante é cuidar desse órgão
maravilhoso que trabalha incansavelmente
para manter você saudável. E lembre-se,
o melhor remédio pro fígado ainda é a
prevenção. Cuide bem dele, que ele cuida
bem de você. Espero que tenham gostado
desse vídeo. Se ficou alguma dúvida,
deixa aí nos seus comentários que a
gente continua essa conversa. Um grande
abraço e até a próxima.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
além do tr se envolva. Ah.